please welcome two-time Academy Award
winner and Academy Governor Tom Hanks
the last time 10 films were nominated
for Best Picture was 1943 the world was
at war and Casablanca took home the big
prize it's now time to find out which
one of this year's ten great films joins
a list that includes that Bogart and
Bergman classic and the winner is The
Hurt Locker Nicolas Chartier
The Hurt Locker has nine Academy Award
nominations this year winning six Oscars
in original screenplay sound editing
sound mixing film editing directing and
Best Picture
thank thank you so much this has been
such a dream beyond a dream for all of
us who have lived for so long with this
story and you know we had this fantasy
of making our film our way with with the
talent that we hope to have and
hopefully we would find a distributor
and and somebody might even like the
movie so to be standing here this was
really truly honestly never part of
anything we even imagined in our wildest
dream so thank you so much to each and
every member of the Academy for for
really honoring us beyond anything we
could have imagined yeah thank you to
the Academy this is really unreal and
extremely humbling we also have to thank
our intrepid financier and fellow
producer Nicholas chargee who bet on
this movie when no one else would the
incredible support that we got from CAA
particularly joel Lubin Brooke
Sutherland Brian sibrel our entire cast
and crew and endless direct our careers
area and also we owe a deep debt of
gratitude by the way to some
entertainment and rob friedman and
patrick wax burger for distributing this
film and thank you mom forgot to thank
you before i was just going to reiterate
that with Robin Patrick who took a very
brave shot with this movie and and we
owe them dearly and may perhaps one more
dedication to men and women all over the
world who sorry to reiterate but wear a
uniform but even not just the military
hazmat emergency firemen you know they
are there for us and we're there for
them thank you thank you
hi congratulations I'll take you out
here with us you have one I'll take this
ladies and gentlemen the show is so long
that avatar now takes place in the past
and alack I just want to say seriously
you're a great actor you're a great
comedian and you're a great guy that's
all the time we have